Tôi chứ cú băng ngành ngoài tháng 2 cho biết là hà bản nè vào hòa xin tơ đang vi trí đến lạc.
Dù các chào đổi hiện nay, chưa phát triển thành một côn cộng đối thoại chính thức.
Cú thể cho lời phòng bình hạn thông tần Rhoiter,
thứ trường ngoài ra khu ba các loast Penandet,
để cô siêu, 9 triển quyền Mỹ đã được thông báo rằng
cú ba sẽ xong tiền thành một cộng đối thoại nghiêm tức,
thực chất và có chính nghiệp.
Tuy nhiên ông Nhân Mạnh, các tiếp xúc mới rất ngã mất chào đổi thông diện thông qua các cân ngoài rao,
chưa cú băng đàn phát triển thức.
Phát biểu gong leo co siêu là lần đầu tiên cú ba sẽ nhận 2 bên có lý là sau khi cân thòng liệu tháng 1,
liên quà m đến các đổng thái của Mỹ tại cú vực.
Chức đó, tổng thủ Mỹ đường đàn trọng phở biến,
Washington đã bao giờ tế vực lời tất cả mát của cú ba và bay tỏ khi vọc đặt được một thật thật.
Mặc dù vầy của nãy xong phương tiếp tục chữ xong át từ các bạn pháp của Mỹ nhằm sét mồn tùng dầu cho cú ba,
khiến nước này đối mắt tình chạm thường như liệu, mất liển và chỉ có tăng cao,
phải cú ba thì cho rằng trên lâu rồi sự em như vậy,
có có thể dưới chỉ lâu dài và sẽ sớm phản tắc dục.